[Music]
the nlm herb garden is uh is one of the
demonstration Gardens that are
maintained by Montgomery County Master
Gardeners we're here 2 to 3 hours one
one day a week to maintain the garden
plant mulch weed trim this was a part of
the National Institutes of Health
celebration of of the bicentennial in
1976 the pic unit herb Society of
America was asked to take over the care
of the garden it was a blessing for me
because I lived close by I was
interested in herbal plants I was
interested in good health so
Rosemary we think of as a culinary herb
Rosemary is said to improve memory and
concentration it was also used to cure
headaches and there are a lot of
culinary herbs in this garden and they
were all used medically this is
valarian was used for insomnia and as a
sedative most of the culinary herbs most
of the herbs we use for
cooking have antibacterial antiviral
anti-inflammatory all kinds of
phytochemicals constituents that now
days we know are
medicinal what I love about this Garden
is this
shows some of the history of
medicine one of the times that I was in
the garden and a young
man a patient from the clinical Center
came into the garden and he
said excuse me I I walk here I walk to
this Garden every
day and I just wanted to thank
you for
it and it was I was a complete mess but
it was still you know with a garden and
you've got textures and colors and
flowers and and it's always
changing and it it was very
important therapeutically to
him and it's certainly therapeutic to
work in it